termino una guerra pero queda una larga
batalla para los afganos el presidente
joe biden puso fin a dos décadas de
conflicto en afganistán con la retirada
de sus tropas en agosto de 2021
6 nos quedamos con una decisión simple o
cumplir con el compromiso asumido por la
última administración y salir de
afganistán o decir que no nos íbamos y
enviar a otras decenas de miles de
tropas más para regresar a la guerra
durante un poco más de dos semanas
aviones militares estadounidenses y de
algunas compañías comerciales realizaron
la evacuación de más de 120.000 personas
entre ciudadanos de eeuu extranjeros y
muchos afganos que trabajaron con ellos
pero se trató de una operación fuera de
control en la que muchos nacionales
intentaron escapar
además el autoproclamado estado islámico
lanzó un ataque suicida con bomba
dejando decenas de muertos las
operaciones militares de eeuu en
afganistán
empezaron en 2001 y terminaron en 2021
con los talibanes y la amistad de línea
dura en el poder antes del fin de las
evacuaciones el 30 de agosto los
talibanes se tomaron casi todo el país
incluida kabul y el presidente afgano
huyó sus planes para formar un nuevo
gobierno se volvieron realidad
world aseguramos al mundo entero
incluido eeuu que el suelo de afganistán
no representará una amenaza para ningún
país incluidos los países vecinos de la
región el grupo talibán intenta
convencer al mundo y a los mismos
afganos de que realmente han cambiado
sus políticas opresivas del pasado sin
embargo siguen excluyendo a varios
sectores de la sociedad y restringiendo
los derechos de las mujeres y las niñas
además se enfrentan a una ruina da
economía desempleo y una crisis
humanitaria que ya anuncia hambruna para
más de la mitad de los 38 millones de
habitantes de la nación